virtual reality is coming whether you
like it or not internet PlayStation
virtual reality ain't no Morpheus no
more and our panel here are you going to
be taking Alexa he'll cross your other
leg a virtual reality cross your leg the
other way there we go hands across now
we're killing it now we're killing it
PlayStation VR playstation vr we've been
talking about V or four feels like eons
yeah couple years at least but we're
sort of on the it's on the horizon
everyone's on the hook now everyone's
kind of thrown down like this is when
we're releasing our thing so we're
getting real close yeah I'm getting
excited we don't have a price yet but I
think we're at the stage now people are
kind of deciding whether or not they're
gonna be picking up a virtual reality
headset and with PlayStation experience
and sort of seeing all the games that
they were old hours I think a lot of
people are you know place a few
foreigners are thinking Oh am I gonna be
putting money aside for a couple of
months and picking up one of these
PlayStation of yours and let's talk
about some of the games that we saw as
shown first of all i'm at the at the
conference at peter what were some of
the ones that jumped out to me res was
by far the most interesting when I hate
to beat a dead horse but as someone who
loved the Dreamcast and loved res in
particular and loves eval curry I see a
lot of things in eve valkyrie mimicked
in res infinite which is like using you
know the direction that you're looking
to sort of aim the reticle and that's
perfect it works so well its eyes one to
one and that's the sort of thing you
want in Virtual Reality you wanted to
mimic what you're doing in real life now
maybe I'm not flying through a simulated
computer space thing filled neon colors
but I can at least feel like I am when
I'm aiming in that direction yeah I love
that and I love that they give that they
give you the flexibility within it
because some people were using just the
head for the radical I was using the
right stick because that's what I'm used
to and they both worked equally well and
what's great as they they work together
in tandem in a really interesting way to
so if I'm like trying to lock on and
then I do one of those things like I did
in the old res where I look over in the
corner of my own I'm just like oh no I
forgot to lock on to that guy just by
looking over to him I've locked on all
right and so it makes the whole thing
just like it's much quicker much easier
you Valkyrie doesn't seem
you need to use it to like lock on the
ships so if you're flying forward you
the ship goes by like hold on a lock on
gotcha yeah it's just sort of like you
know that analog yep to what you would
do in and it's brilliant I mean that
that aesthetic like I keep saying it's
it's such a simple aesthetic which works
wonderfully in VR everybody wants to
build this crazy realistic city that you
can walk around yeah this hardware is
just not there yet I early VR is gonna
be all about good art direction and that
something Reza's always has it looks
like it hasn't aged a day when you look
at it there's something about that
design aesthetic that is a Gucci put
into it that's just like brilliant and
fresh today the same way it was in 2001
well because it's interesting because
you know we're so used to seeing these
one-to-one like one of the biggest
problems of yours like how do you move
around and you get people to move around
if they can move around in their space
do we have it sodas they use a
controller or do we have it so they know
you lean forward and you can move around
spaces that way yeah where's like
actually you can make lots of different
for your experiences that aren't 121
matches with you being in a human body
well that's something that Tim Schaefer
was talking about because you know
psychonauts VR the rhombus of ruin was
one of the big announcements and he was
talking about how it will not be a
traditional game where you're where
you're moving around it's going to use
razzes psychic powers and like maybe
you're jumping from one person's head to
another and that's how you get around
they're going to fall back on their
adventure game pedigree and make it very
much dialogue based in story based and I
think that's going to work so
wonderfully it's interesting about Alexa
you were talking earlier about how like
you tend to not try a lot of you are
because you get motion sick but you
didn't weirdly enough with res which
kind of feels like a game that's
throwing you around quite a lot so I've
never I've never tried the Morpheus
before him on my last PlayStation VR
edition PR and my last experience was
maybe almost two years ago I played like
an oculus at an event and got I played
me Valkyrie right you just got violently
ill like I get motion sick from
first-person shooters if I'm not careful
ever seen cloverfield that movie made me
much yes then you're gonna love
Cloverfield VR but I played so I play
friends and I
it's because maybe it wasn't like it oh
here are my hands here is my body and
I'm just doing it but I actually got
really brave and did that I did the head
tracking and i used the head and at one
point there was like a lull in the music
and I looked down it's just the tracks
going by me and it's like a little
disorienting but I didn't get sick and
I'm very excited now because maybe it's
like I don't know if it's like res in
particular or the fact that its third
person or the fact that the Morpheus is
like the morgue [ __ ] the PlayStation be
comfortable yeah i'm just not and is and
I don't feel disoriented I don't know if
it's that or but I feel like a whole new
world has been opened up to me now I've
been avoiding it for so long this works
it's strange with so much of what we've
seen it seems like they're figuring
adaption yeah like you over the pasta
tutors or longer we've seen like
iterations on this technology and it
feels like for usability sake and also
like the types of games we're seeing
like it's all sort of clicking into
place yeah what I've noticed what I've
noticed and I just kind of clicked with
me now after hearing Alexis say this is
the things that are working the best for
me are things where you're either some
sort of body or object free-floating or
you're locked to one space like in job
simulator where ya at a desk because you
kind of get around that whole like why
does it look like I'm walking but I'm
not walking why does my body want to
vomit more than anything ever in the
world right now I had so much fun with
job simulator like obviously you know
type of experience it probably isn't too
much fun to play over and over and over
again but like just the you know I
wonder will this work and then it works
like I picked up the plant and put in
the coffee machine and i found this disc
and i put it into the computer and ended
up being like a flappy bird clones got
loaded on kind of like surgeons in guys
love your idiot baby hands just like
mashing on the keyboard there there's no
fun oh it's mary doing a shot oh it's
Mary's idiot baby but then on the other
side good Mary is what i meant to say i
picked right there you go
yeah there's the idiot baby I I'm on the
other side of that room I play driveclub
and I laid it and I dunno the racing
games of ER I'm actually that kind of
felt like it didn't really work I kind
of felt like it was well you don't meet
we here's the thing everybody thinks
that racing is going to be like the
perfect natural fit and it sort of is
but it's also the thing that needs BR
the least rice because I sort of always
looking forward keeping your eye on the
track and what's going on and so it was
very rare that i actually used any head
tracking it yeah clap like in most
racing disciplines you're like even your
wind mirrors are like within you know I
flicking layer you know I guess of why
you're split your I folk impressive
thing about the drive club demo was they
were showing off how far the PlayStation
VR headset has come since that initial
prototype right the same way they're
showing off the how far the oculus has
come and things like that as their you
know raising these frame rates and these
refresh rates and everything is getting
brighter and the head tracking is
getting more one-to-one they're just
trying to show off like hey we can do an
experience like this now and it will not
make alexa ray corriea vomit much it's
comfortable too isn't it like that unit
Peter you I feel like of all the people
at gamespot your views view or the most
and you're the most experienced we're
using all the different iterations of
these how do you think that PlayStation
view our headset feels because to me it
like it's so light it feels super easy
to like move on your head and everything
yeah I mean as these things develop you
know obviously the materials get refined
they realize they don't need as much
circuit board they can they can find
lighter materials that wick away
moisture and stuff and these things
become more comfortable and I think some
people will always find something to
complain about but really yeah like the
Morpheus is really comfortable oculus it
is really comfortable even the latest
gear VR I mean people are iterating on
these pretty quickly and coming up with
solutions discuss max for demo those
poor guys that's the bomb there it is of
that was not uh this is that did not go
well for them and you know if you look
at how fast it's progressed already over
the past three years project 10 years
down the road right right I mean these
things will continue to shrink continue
to be more comfortable we are at like
the the frontier of VR even now still
after years of doing this stuff it
hasn't hit marker
really it's it's not really gone
mainstream and gotten the money to keep
making more things and keep refining it
so it's just going to get smaller and
more comfortable so unit it's not
perfect right now don't discount it like
the some of the early experiences are
great and they totally make up for a
little bit of discomfort because you get
an experience unlike anything you've
played on a traditional TV with a cup
with control I think that's a great
point I think if it can make it through
these first three or four years if these
companies can really like stick it out
keep supporting it don't pull money out
of it to say the way they pulled money
out of like a connect or a move or
something like that as long as they
don't get bored and see the prophets
kind of not coming in for the first
three or four years I think this is
something that could really catch on but
it's something where they're going to
have to commit to backing well the thing
is that most people now at least in our
groups right we talk about this as a
game first device but the r is being
utilized and I guess I've said this a
lot of times I feel like I'm repeating
myself but it's used for therapy yeah a
lot like burn victims heal faster
walking through snow NVR you know PTSD
people are able to overcome these
memories that haunt them by reliving
them in a different content so those are
the sort of things and even like
airlines like putting VR in the seats
those are the sort of things that are
going to support the v yarn yeah games
will it benefit as a result yeah I would
be shocked if it didn't continue down
the road it's already going I mean you
see somebody like Samsung jump in bed
with with oculus and you know and then
Facebook owning oculus like those are
two big powerhouses they are not going
to just get their toes wet and sure it
will it's cold they're gonna jump in you
know full force and will continue to do
so well I think that's interesting
because then that brings up like Sony I
mean Sony obviously is thinking about
this in terms of movies entertainment
and games but they're sort of they're
not on the forefront of like those same
sort of things that you're talking about
with these research companies where it's
like well they don't really put money
into things like therapies and that
source of so there may be the company
that has the most to lose but also I
think has the best chance of getting a
toehold in the consumer market because
I'm not going to have to have a high end
pc to their box is already in my living
room these games already run to spec
without me having to fiddle with
anything the way you have to with an
oculus or anything right now so they
have the they have a big chance to kind
of take the living room
which i think is interesting and you can
really see from like all their PSX
presentations that they really want the
living room they want it so bad right
now cheers to see diversity for that
living room curious to see what valve
does know that they've started their
whole steam machine initiative although
it's not taken off very well you know
how far are they from having a box that
they sanction is being this is the you
know the valve er box yeah right and
that'll sort of get rid of all the
high-end PC stuff because really
developers just have to aim for a
certain spec like they're doing you know
as you described at the PlayStation 4 so
I could see you know HTC cornering the
pc market where the valves help down the
road I mean that could be a theme that
works out really well for them but for
gamers in general i love that we're
talking about all this only all these
lofty technology goals and everything
like that and all i want to do is play
hundred-foot robot golf with ya so like
we talk about when we talk about this as
we started projecting like you know five
or ten years in the future and it feels
like there's so much like it not
optimism but people are fighting for VR
in a way that they didn't reconnect and
move like pina or even seems like more
and more people are so that they wanted
to work so like sort of Real Talk 2016
PlayStation VR comes out I know where
maybe though it's skewed a little bit
because we're people who do this
professionally but like how who's going
to buy one like Alexa are you going to
get when he said it didn't make me barf
so hmm I'd like to that's actually the
top of your scale yeah first scale goes
her scale goes from fainting and
vomiting to didn't make me Barbie
Bartlett I'm excited about that because
everyone's talking about the yard yeah
you ask you guys all come back from
shows and it's like oh I played this act
like that and I'm like okay so that's
like you didn't want to be left out of
that conversation so I wonder if there's
gonna be enough people who buy this who
then you know that early adopter thing
where they're like push everyone else
until so I'm gonna have three headsets
in my house by the end of next you
really think you it really am going to
have three headsets in my house I am an
idiot I will do it I love it that we
don't know which one pornhub is gonna go
with right don't till I know yeah until
because I want to play robot golf but i
also want to get up on that robot
something else yesterday razor because
they have their own open source VR
headset okay CEO of razor tweeted out
and i'm not saying we're supporting porn
out of
box I am saying there is a native app
for the only view our porn producer out
there Wow on arc device out of the bar
headsets Danny out of the bar i'm going
to have no Peter I'm assuming you'll
probably jump in on a bunch of them yeah
I mean I'm yes I think I even though I
am like really passionate about it i
will probably go for the easiest
solution first hmm um samsung gear vr is
great but i don't really like Samsung
phones alright so for me it will
probably be the PlayStation VR I have a
ps4 I like some of the demos that
they've put out I will have a rift in
time but in time is the key word so do
we think that PlayStation 4 runners are
going to pick this up because by the
time this comes out we will be two and a
half in coming up to three years after a
console as come out maybe that takes the
sting out of having to spend whatever it
is that asks act like its people ready
for the next best thing and it's not
gonna come for another seven years right
right yeah why wouldn't it's all gonna
be about price point though I think it's
all gonna be about price point the
camera D said for less than like 300
riders so they could they could easily
subsidize it oh right yeah you think I
think so but what they that's the big
question you think so I think they will
I to get people to anybody this is
really going to catch fire is if people
are at their friend's house and using
right so Sony can't get this into
people's hands right it's not they're
not gonna be able to market it so well
with a commercial it's going to be
experiencing it because I've talked to
people about VR a thousand times and
it's not until like you tried that demo
again yeah you were like oh wow okay and
me and Andy baman went into that room
the the sort of VO room that they had
for the price and he's kind of like he
gets hot and cold on the sort of stuff
and when he put the headset on he came
over and went you know I like we watch
videos of people like playing VR all the
time like this stuff he's like we're
just gonna shoot more b-roll of this
stuff and it doesn't really put it
across he was like I put the headset on
I was like oh yeah sorry I remember this
is [ __ ] amazing but you know the big
the big thing that really made me go all
in at PSX was we're finally seeing games
yet seeing a lot of demos of like pick
up a thing and you're in a forest and
look around and it's like no this is a
game I'm a lot of them yeah like it
feels like there's now I'm at the stage
where I can't name all the VR games that
are coming
on on Playstations but fought for and
that's important because I think people
were seeing it as this long-term tech
demo now it's kind of like oh yes
hundred-foot robot golf I guess did you
know you could pick up stuff and put it
in the photocopier and it made
duplicates I am like 15 Donuts by the
end of this game yeah that's really need
to work like that thank Laura that is
[ __ ] tea Earl Grey that's on him
virtual reality there you go we have
four to four thumbs up or you know maybe
eight we can go and here on the couch
let us know what you think of VR do you
want to play station 4 you're going to
pick up a PlayStation VR yourself and
what's the right price point let us know
in the comments below